oh boy oh boy I think I got a game for
you guys today it's called Hi-Fi Rush
it's made by the people that developed
stuff like The Evil Within Tango studio
and it's published by Bethesda games and
I think it's going to be an interesting
fresh take in the type of games they
normally make it's on the Xbox series
console and it's on PC and this is my
review for Hi-Fi Rush on the Xbox series
X let's get on with it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
what's going on you guys Lord ad here
coming out with another review enough
took a little bit of time off any time
to recuperate but now we'll be right
back at it and the reviews we'll be
reviewing quite a bit of games here in
the next couple weeks here on the iron
Lords podcast Channel and today we're
going to be reviewing high five Rush
developed by Tango Gameworks and
published by Bethesda software Studio
first off we're going to talk about you
know the general story of this game and
you know the artwork a little bit as
well now the artwork of this game I
would actually say is one of its core
components now when I first saw this
game I don't generally like these type
of games that don't really take
themselves seriously I'll and I for one
probably lean more towards a realistic
approach but I did see this in the art
styles unique now look at something like
Sunset Overdrive I would say the art
styles a little bit in that direction
now a lot of people like to compare this
game overall to Sunset Overdrive but I
don't think that's a fair comparison now
I would have loved for for this game to
get the kind of budget that Sunset
Overdrive have but I do feel like that
comparison isn't really valid in this
point now let's talk about the story the
story you start out as a wannabe rock
star named chai pretty sure that's how
you pronounce his name probably butcher
that as well he opens up in a room that
he has a broken arm or something of that
matter and it looks like he's having
some type of upgrade now he does get an
artificial arm and stuff kind of goes
weird after that it does look like he is
able to interact with metals and stuff
around him and he is able to form it
onto a weapon that he usually make a
guitar or something like that now first
off the gameplay of this game is a lot
of rhythm-based combat now I know what a
lot of you are saying addicts I don't
like rhythm-based games neither do I at
all you know but I will say that this
game doesn't punish you for not having a
rhythm what it does is it gives you
bonuses it rewards you it doesn't really
give you any negative effects from
missing timing now if you want to you
know perhaps get all the achievements or
get S ranks on everything then you're
probably got to learn that Rhythm based
gameplay towards it but what I like here
that Tango studio did is they knew that
a lot of people wouldn't do stuff like
that they knew that some people would be
like yo I just don't like the Rhythm
stuff so what they did is they made a
combat that you know similar to
something like Bayonetta Devil May Cry
now it is not a serious tone of those
games because this game is consistently
making fun of itself and I think that
for the most part it does it very well
you know you look at games like high on
life it has shown that that type of
humor is acceptable if you do it
correctly and I think there's a lot of
games that aren't doing it correctly but
this particular game is definitely doing
it correctly in the gameplay you you
have a lot of variety in terms of
combating here you have combos from
heavy attacks to pretty much basic
attacks and what I like about this is
they did put another type of Rhythm
based in this game where you know you
got the rhythm of the world around you
and then you got the rhythm of the
combat that you have to time for
instance when you attack someone you
know let's say three basic attacks what
happens is this green bar comes down and
if you time it correctly they reward you
for doing that with stuff like the
batteries that you get for leveling up
your super there's a lot of different
stuff that they put in here to reward
the people who really do want to learn
that that rhythm-based combat but at the
same time if you don't want to do that
you can easily play through the whole
game and not really worry about it now I
really like that and I think that
especially when you play the combat
you'll see this game is extremely
Variety in types of how you want to play
there is there's a grappling hook where
you can constantly get in the face of
your enemy and attack them they have
these you unique characters and I don't
want to really go too much into it and
spoil anything but you can actually
switch out on a certain attack for
instance there will be a shield on a
particular enemy and you know you
yourself can't do nothing to that enemy
but through the game you unlock these
Side characters that can come out and do
an attack kind of look at like a Marvel
versus uh the Marvel vs Street Fighter
franchise where you could actually have
someone pull up and they'll attack and
then they'll go they'll leave now you
have something similar to that on here
to where it's like I said you have a
shield person with a Blue Shield there's
a character that you can unlock through
the story and what will happen is when
you see these barriers on the field you
can use that character to destroy them
what I like about is there's multiple of
these characters so they do unique
things on the battlefield you know you
have a lot of rhythm-based stuff going
on there as well you know you have
enemies that have armor on that you need
another character to break the armor you
have enemies that can catch on fire that
you use that character to blow them out
you know that one seemed a little bit
less used than the rest it did feel like
they wanted you to really use the other
two characters the most but I'm not
going to say that the other character
wasn't used because it was used you know
when it comes to this game what's really
good about Hi-Fi Rush is the ability to
play this game in a lot of different
variety of ways what I mean by that is
there's a store and you can upgrade how
you want to play you can upgrade the
combos that you want to use in the store
There's an actual place in the store
where you can get more unique abilities
from the people that's actually helping
you out so for instance you know one
ability you can unlock where you do a
certain combo in the air and one of
these people will bring out like a giant
gun and shoot so there's a variety of
ways that you can play Hi-Fi rush and I
think they need to get a lot of props
for that because a lot of these times
you know when it comes to you know
side-on characters that do stuff in the
game they mainly use them for some form
of platforming and look there is
platforming in this game we'll get to
that here in a second but I do feel like
they did a really good job being diverse
with how you want to play this game with
these characters in terms of the
platforming I won't say that it was
amazing I will say that it was good at
times worse at other times but I don't
think this game's really designed to be
entices when it comes to platforming I
think it's just something that you use
to get around the map something you get
used to get around the level what I like
about this game is every level that you
do on here feels unique in way some way
shape or form they're very big on
Switching up the gameplay so you don't
feel like you're doing stuff for too
long and I'm really appreciative of that
I feel like that's another thing that
some developers get wrong they continue
to have you do the same type of gameplay
mechanics rotation for just about the
entire game after you get through the
tutorial I kind of felt like I was
learning a lot in this game even almost
to the end of the game and I think
that's one thing that you know is really
incisive to playing this game is you
could go go back and play it a few times
they do have some post game stuff to
where once you beat the game you can
jump in a little bit more they have a
lot of cosmetic items that isn't micro
transactioned you know you get the
in-game currency and you can use that
money to buy anything your heart
contents including cosmetics and props
to them because they could have easily
have put some form of microtransactions
in there where you could buy it with
real money now stuff like that doesn't
really bother me as long as it's not a
multiplayer game but it's nice that
these type of Cosmetics was in the game
and you can actually buy them yourself
it's cool now look is it like a huge
amount of a selection no not really but
they did do enough to make your
characters look more unique than the
person next to you and I appreciate that
for those of you that's been following
me for a while you know I'm a huge
component when it comes to boss fights
and I can honestly say that the boss
fights on this game is very unique and
well done they change things up multiple
times during the fight most the time
when you play something like a from
software game you'll see that they'll
change things up depending on how much
damage you do most of these time when
you fight a boss on hi-fi rush they got
four or five bars that lead up to one
health bar and they're pretty much
saying look if you get me down to this
I'm out of health I'm going to change
things up and I like that because some
bosses in here I would say change things
up at least twice and I really enjoy
that because it never it keeps you on
your toes the entire time you're
fighting them but it never feels like
they're doing too much it feels like
it's the same person sometimes I hate
when they put these type of mechanics
Annex in a game and instead of just
changing what the actual character does
they just change the character in
general you know I like a phase where
you fight with a bar and then another
phase where maybe it's a little bit more
of a long range weapon or you know they
shoot lightning through one of the
weapons and one of the fights on here
and I I really like that and you know
all the bosses I would say have a really
good Charisma you know when you're
fighting and you're laughing because of
the jokes that's going on between them I
do think that the story builds up pretty
well and especially the last couple
levels on hi-fi rush really impressed me
and especially when you add the licensed
music that they use in this game some of
the music when you're fighting bosses
can be very epic you feel like it's just
going down left and right and I think
that was intentional to make you really
be on your toes when you're fighting
these individuals now look this game is
amazing but it's got its faults you know
I do feel like the story is good as it
was told I felt like the budget wasn't
really there in her terms of you know
the cinematics I do feel like this game
if it would have had a budget like
Sunset Overdrive you know just to make
it more expansive make the world more
expansive you know I do like how they
change the biomes that you're in here
quite a bit where you don't feel like
you're only in one little office area or
something like that they did a really
good job on that but I just I feel like
the way they told the narrative could
have changed a little bit now I'm not
gonna like use it as a standpoint not to
buy the game because I don't think it's
worth not buying because of that but if
I were to ask for a Hi-Fi Rush too
that's probably one of the only
criticisms I would give like true
criticism it's like I think you could
have made the game look better and you
could have you know told the story in a
little bit better maybe more cinematics
maybe build up the world a little bit
more I do feel like the beginning of the
game is kind of a mystery on what
happens and they do a good job
explaining throughout the game but it's
just like get more context at the
beginning explain who we are where what
what's happening and I think you know
the presentation could have been a
little bit better in terms of how they
were traveling The Narrative of this
game but like I said I wouldn't use any
of that against it look at the end of
the day you guys know how I do these
things you know I don't really tell you
a one through ten rating I always tell
you whether or not it's worthy of your
money this game if I remember correctly
is 40 bucks on Stevens and Game Pass now
obviously if it's on Game Pass you guys
should be playing this already this is
definitely worth a download by all means
go home right now or click off this
video right now and you know go ahead go
on that Xbox you know that PC game pass
and click download I think this is
definitely something that's worth
downloading and you guys will really
enjoy now if you want to buy it because
you want to own the actual game I
definitely understand that and for 30
bucks it's definitely worth that now I
even think they probably could have
snuck us a fast when it got 60 for this
I'm glad they didn't because I feel like
this game's gonna do better at that
price point I do feel like the game
gaming industry will try to charge you
sixty seventy dollars for a title that a
lot of consumers isn't worth 60 or 70
dollars I think the only people that
hurt in the end is the developers that
made the game because they know that
with that type of price point it's
harder to sell but I do think 30 is
definitely worth it I would actually
recommend picking up the 40 deluxe
edition because that's just how good
this game is you get you know some parts
with that I assume and it just shows a
little bit more appreciation to we got
to support the good games that do come
out and the ones especially that they
give you Cosmetics that don't try to
charge you extra money for Hi-Fi Rush is
a change of pace that I think the
industry desperately needs it's the type
of indie game slash you know AAA budget
I would say because Microsoft is funding
this at this point so is bethesda's
before Microsoft bought them where it's
like these are the type of titles that's
going to carry us to the promised land
these are the type of titles that's
going to try unique things that big AAA
products such as you know the star
Fields out there don't really
necessarily want to risk trying because
they know it's untested in the market
and these type of games have the
flexibility to try new things and I
think Hi-Fi Rush did a good job at
making a rhythm game that doesn't
enforce you to play by its rules now I
know to a lot of people that are like
but addict if it's a rhythm game and
they're not making you play by the
Rhythm rules of the game isn't that
making it too easy in a couple ways I
would agree with you but at the same
time this is one of those aspects where
making something making it more
accessible is definitely going to
benefit the brand and the product in the
future because sure it's different than
making a game easier or harder or you
know a little bit harder this is pretty
much saying look we want to we want to
make a rhythm game we want to make a
game revolved around music and we want
that Rhythm based combat there but we
don't want to penalize you through we
don't want people to see this game and
say yo I don't like this and I'm not
gonna play it we want people to see why
I won't give it a chance and now since
they've been more open to the
rhythm-based combat I think they're
going to get a lot more people talking
about this game and I would be very
surprised if Microsoft's not working on
a second one I definitely recommend this
for 30 bucks and highly recommend it for
Game Pass and PC game pass I think every
one of you would enjoy this game even if
you don't like Rhythm based games like I
don't I can't stand them for the most
part I enjoyed this game thoroughly but
you know that's pretty much the review I
thought the gameplay was fantastic the
story was good could have been better
and I felt like the artwork was really
well done maybe it could have been a
little bit better with you know better
budgeting in the future it's like I said
those things are more nitpicking for a
Hi-Fi Rush too and not necessarily
issues with this game as it stands but
that's pretty much my opinion on hi-fi
Rush developed by Tango software and
published by Bethesda and I hope you
enjoyed this review keep in mind I
reviewed it on the Xbox series X and
until next time this is Lord addict of
the iron Lords podcast definitely tune
in for our podcast every Sunday at 1pm
and until the next review this is Lord
addict I'm out of here peace